-I'm sorry to do this,
before we move on...
there is something
that's been bothering me
that I need
to get off my chest.
I was at an important charity
gala dinner this morning...
[ Laughter ]
How did we miss that all week?
And we proofread these things
so many times.
Literally the first line
of this piece...
I was at
an important charity gala dinner
this morning...
[ Laughter ]
When this is over,
I'm going to have a second thing
to get off my chest.
[ Laughter ]
I was having a great time
getting buzzed on fizzy wine
when the affair took a turn.
An acquaintance of mine
soured an otherwise
delightful conversation
by confiding in me that he was
turning 50 soon
and he was scared.
He said the best parts
of life are over,
and he said he regretted
all the things
he'd never got to do
while he was young.
Needless to say,
I thought his blubbering
was a big reeking pile of crap,
and, lo, I told him so!
Clutching his lapels
and shaking him like a rag doll,
I shouted,
"Stop being a pathetic whiner!"
And I'm sorry to anyone else
feeling weird about their age,
but I don't.
Because here's
the bottom line --
50 is the new 20!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-And the only thing
your 30-under list
is good for is to wipe my ass!.
Whew! That felt good
to get off my chest.
We'll be right back
with Paul Giamatti, everybody.